people will connect with you because  they feel like you're like them and  what we often share is too perfect you  know someone would look at me and my  youtube growth and the success and the  mastermind and the beach gang and you  know the people i hang out with and it's  just it's makes it seem like well so you  know it's easy for you i'm not like that  you're so natural in the camera all of  this stuff right like well no but go  back and look  look at my early days and i love sharing  these kinds of things this graphic is on  my home page every month i'll share this  on on instagram too and my social of how  my youtube growth has come along